so how did you get your start in dota 2
casting what came first was it dota was
it the casting was it streaming it was
protostellar it was just playing the
game so I was playing it for about two
years before I really started to even
think about cutting before even you
about the eSports scene at all I'm you
know with games like dota and normally
when the average person like myself sees
it on Steam starts to pick it up and
play it
you're totally oblivious to the fact
that there's this massive competitive
scene going on and it was a couple of
years in that I started to kind of move
more to watching it on Twitch now it's a
way that you know hang on people take
this game kind of seriously you know
there's people playing this game for a
living making money from it and there's
people who cover it and I kind of had a
background in audio production I was
studying music technology at the time
and I've worked on kind of local radio
stations so as I can kind of put two and
two together and I started to kind of
exercise a little bit by doing a lot of
a UK casting just casting smaller stuff
in my own country bringing a Luna down
though and great look shot again ah
stands out from the sound King mr.
Bharani my first reactions in the first
game was this games absolutely awful
I didn't like it at all I picked sniper
I went say I pick sniper because he had
a gun you know I come from console
gaming is coming home kind of plain
called you in the mates no but this
guy's got a girly must be pretty good
took him in the safe lane it wasn't
pretty I had no idea what I was doing in
fact if you look back at my first few
pages on dota buff its I literally just
build built wings of perseverance I mean
they gave you health they gave you a
manner I mean what more could you want
you want to cast spells you want to live
this is the item that you need to buy so
I really didn't know I was doing played
a few games I remember back in the day I
was level one with the XP bar moving
forward it would move like a tiny bit
for one game I was like geez how would
anyone ever level up you got to play
this game a lot and I saw that you could
pay for cosmetics so like who'd do that
you know everything's expensive or he
doesn't have the range doesn't have the
length that's why his wife meets up with
a guy behind the shed on a Tuesday when
I wanted to start to cast I didn't
really have the kind of the balls the
guts to do on my own so I was talking to
my may and I was like hey Joyner don't
to try casting out together so we
started doing this kind of a powering
thing that we both live very close to
each other so we had the ability to kind
of set
you know very kind of roughs to do my
bedroom where we could come round and it
could be a bit of fun because we could
then compete with other amateur casters
that you know most amateur casters kind
of in the bedroom with like their
headsets you know we could actually get
a proper set up because I had the kit
from my from my degree that I was be
using anyway for music and audio and he
could come round we could set up
something between the two of us and do
some of those kind of on a little level
above which I think certainly helped us
kind of get discovered at the start and
people were like hey these guys are
actually putting a lot more effort in
than say a lot of your amateur casters
and I think that's one of the keys ready
to kind of getting your career off the
ground at the beginning correctly from
Ron was the first lead that you start
casting for was it amateur dota 2 league
yeah was yeah that's right in the
beginning Richard it was great there's a
fair few forums like I believe there's
the dota 2 cast its subreddit which you
can go on and there's always people kind
of won in games to be casted and I think
it was on there you I saw some amateur
leagues and all the amateur leagues
there's so many amateur leagues which
are the great thing about dota 2 in the
ticket system you know it's very simple
for someone to go up and set up a
tournament and leave for kind of that
you know the tier 4 and below teams you
know people that you know just a couple
of mates you know who want to have a bit
of a game that's oh come on a bit more
of a serious level than just your
standard kind of rank matchmaking that
all these games be no people looking for
them too cause you won't get a lot of
viewers you may get 10 but I was doing
that for about probably about a year and
a half before anyone really knew me I
was streaming casting games that a
maximum you know be crazy if we hit like
20 viewers or something it would be seen
as well this is really cool twenty
people are watching us and but it
definitely helps at the beginning you
may feel like a lot not a lot but
definitely a year and a half down the
line I'd look back and I'd be like
actually casting on these amateur games
was essential and has really helped me
improve as a conference or the ancient
seal maybe is but it gets overgrowth
where it's loader there he is he's
swarming it is you're gonna be on top
you know I'm sure a lot of people have
been in the situation where you have
that period where you want to be a
twitch stream you wanna you want to go
online and and show yourself and have
someone else watching at the beginning
if it's just one person appearing in
chat like a randomest you know not your
friend not your family someone you don't
know that's come in and is showing an
interest in what you're doing it feels
great and when you got 20 people doing
that at the start you say oh you've got
a little kind of community that's tuning
in people starting to be like hey who's
this guy hey this is kind of good I mean
even you know some out the 20 they'll
tune in and be like this guy's awful
this guy sucks but that's great because
they
when you hear hundred you've got more
people telling you that you suck and
that's when you know hey people actually
care enough to come here and tell me
that I suck and that's kind of the
beginning of where you start to get the
ball rolling more people start to kind
of find out who you are
my first break was definitely the three
hour and 20 minute game that I did for
BTS which was a very fortunate series of
circumstances it was in fact I believe
the first game that beyond the summit
allowed me to cast on the main channel
so it was literally I've been casting
with a small stuff you know I think the
maximum stream I'd have maybe with like
a thousand viewers or something and I
was hosting it from my bedroom they said
you want to cast this game clown line
versus scary faces and then they were
like by the way your code cast is purged
and at the time I was I purged that's
pretty legit this man's like a big name
he's the guy that I watch the videos of
and they got put in casting with me so I
was kind of like okay I got to keep it
cool got to keep it cool I got to the
game and I can't remember which gear
game in the series I think it was Game
two
or Game one potentially but I remember
just casting it was really good with
hers because he's such a nice guy and
you know he he never cast it with me I
doubt that even maybe even seen my class
before so he didn't know what to expect
but as the game went on and on I
remember like the words I think we're
like two hours in I was like Pudge
imagine if this went on for another hour
and he was like oh that's definitely not
gonna happen oldie and it did you know
if it went on for three hours and twenty
minutes
there's so many fun and Kalani's
happening you gotta be fun and clowning
yourself normal stay sit here you kind
of sit there be serious now around three
hours into the game and I just got
himself a 95 but he's boring you know
you're bringing the music you know you
just trying to keep people interested
you know that especially with a game
like that people are going to be
watching them might not even know
anything about don't you know that the
news will start spreading people going
to be watching the three hour 20 minute
match that they don't really have a clue
what's going on so you've just got to
make it entertaining and especially
seeing as my first kind of break I was
like I've got to do something here
that's gonna make people talk about this
I've got to go around this the right way
aren't you in shock here we
but they bring it up Oh seven so quick
he's dead they're going for the ancient
can they do it oh no Angie rage is dead
her all died
triple kill the ancient the age of black
dragon caddy dude don't know he can't
they're all dead I think we peaked it
like 90,000 viewers and I was kind of
sat there you know with my OBS open with
the twitch channel I've got 90,000
people watching this stream at the time
I was kind of panicking you know it's my
first kind of big kind of exposure and I
was like people are gonna be watching
this and because it's three hours long
they're gonna kind of point out my flaws
you know you're three hours into a car
you're not going to be the best ability
so I'm like this is the first time
ninety thousand people have seen me I've
got to kind of nail it it's gotta be
jayjay see when they lay their game oh
my god
it won't tell you no it's only my
Twitter followers I think they went from
like 500 to like 3,000 which was a huge
boom I was having people talk about me
on like Reddit and stuff I'd gone over
forums as well and people were saying
good things positive things and it was
it was a really good start and a really
good boost and that kind of led to be
getting invited to do the dream League
the great thing with dream League is it
so it's an event by event basis
so they weren't saying hey you're good
we want you to just be a dream League
caster it was literally James I'm gonna
be adding me on skype against anything
as thought so I got this ad from James -
good hiding and I was like oh my god -
cos added me on Sky View this is here
and then he was just like hey things
like do you want to do dream be alright
what you mean you mean dream Lee the
thing that you guys do are you sure and
you're like yeah come on
yeah let's do it should I go quit my job
News life yeah you probably should go
quit your job okay so I literally went
down to the down to the boots that I
worked in the booth chemist and Hannah
my notes in there like what you gonna do
I was like I'm gonna go to Sweden cast
computer games they're like you sure you
wanna quit all right
yeah I'm sure when I quit it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be great yes indeed
thank you very much panel my name's Odie
pixel I'm in with cinder and dota did
you just adjust your chair sir you're
taller than me now we're ready to get
ourselves into an RP verse and yeah I
went over to Sweden and yeah relocated
for just a couple of months but it you
know it's fine you know interesting it
for a few months I was totally up for
that and it was definitely the right the
best decision I made to to take it and
there was no chance I was gonna say no
to it
I don't really kind of turned up the
scene in May you know T I was what in
August so it's very soon I was like man
I wouldn't have been surprised if I
wasn't invited but you do the qualifiers
you know people start to say things like
hey I've heard you're going to TI and
you know it's like you cut it out with
people that you know the hear rumors no
one really knows for sure until bout
gives the official word and but then
it's like a few weeks before they always
leave the invites nice and late and I
got a message and it was like hey you're
coming to the International and I was
like damn as I've never been to America
before so I was pretty excited and then
the International was pretty much as
good as I could have hoped for it was it
was just a great experience and I was
just really grateful that found kind of
gave me the shot because I think it was
a little bit of a risk you know it still
kind of knew I remember you know those
threads kind of coming up saying in bio
D to TI but then there's a lot of
responses you know that were kind of
being like a little bit new you know
he's not ready yet you know he should
necessarily rushed into this you know
people saying I don't really like him
enough to be on that kind of stage but
then I went on you know I just gave him
my best you know I took all the
criticism onboard you know I realized
this was a very prestigious event I
don't want to mess it up you know I
totally understand the guys sitting at
home they don't to see just some random
guy casting you know the biggest
tournament of all time it's a a very big
responsibility for me to have on my
shoulders so I just I just kind of gave
it my best shot
I put a lot of work in just to make sure
I was kind of on the same level as the
other casters and you know touch but it
seems to have gone well because I'm
still casting afterwards I wasn't
written off it wasn't like this guy
who's it was an absolute mistake never
getting casting anything again so it was
a big break but I just had to kind of do
my best to make sure I did as much as I
could with it you know I think even just
last Christmas I've been thinking about
Ti and I'm gonna buy as no I can get by
it because it because it was such a
quick rise I'd never expect that I get
into a position where people were
actually asking for me to go in cast at
the International so it's kind of crazy
but I think it's a really good thing in
the sense that what's great to me
because I'm incredibly fortunate you
know I'm living this incredible life
that I could have imagined that I'd be
living you know this time
last year it was ridiculous I didn't
know I was going to be doing I felt like
I no prospects I finished my degree but
it wasn't necessarily the best degree to
get a job in I was just with a working
kind of part-time living with my parents
and kind of just holding on to this hope
that I could make it as a caster that
you know inside me I believed that I
could but it was getting to the point
where I was like maybe I'm a little bit
delusional maybe this isn't for me and
maybe this isn't something that I can
break through into I just kind of stuck
at it and I think yeah as I'm saying if
anything it kind of just shows people
out there that it is possible to do how
do you feel about the meme of people
comparing you to Eminem calling the Red
Guard
I mean that's kind of cool I guess it
just comes from the fact that I speak
really fast and originally you know I
don't really listen to a lot of madmen
and I actually listen to more now that
people started comparing me to it I'm
like hey I should start listening for
this and then I can maybe one day you
know do an M&M cover or some use it as a
bit of a laugh a bit of a joke but I
guess it's not a bad comparison I mean
it's a successful guy so if you want to
compare me to Eminem alright it's gone
Phoenix can they do it - you're tearing
it up eat they don't have bye-bye
it's not looking good for the design
he's ready to alternate fight up against
G but Jimmy pops the cheese now he's
gonna hit against the big who's got back
to base I think this is mega creeps and
lights under I think this is GG well
played
you